receive this outlined way back in August
of last year that's actually couple of
months before Game of Thrones started
filming its final season that's a couple
of months before any leaked photo was
taken and yet the south line matches
perfectly with all the leaks and leaked
photos that followed I already shared
outlines for the first four episodes of
the final season so if you haven't seen
them yet make sure to do so and then
come back to watch this video the way
you're caught up with everything that
has already happened before I start let
me warn you once again that this leaked
outline does seem to be legit so if you
don't want anything spoiled it's time
for you to close this video ok the
outline claims that the episode starts
with the unsullied men in the city walls
with city and salad with the dragon
lasted Spears we see the gun company
carrying a giant glass made weapons we
also see ground Quivers lined up against
the wall filled with arrows featuring
laser heads
I got a stop right there to point out
that this part of the outline has been
confirmed by leaked photos here you can
see the unsullied Manning the walls of
King's Landing set and here on the left
side of the picture you can see crowned
Quivers the torture shoes when they're
shooting from a fixed location lined up
against the wall just like the outline
states the previous episode saucers
inviting the limb inside to stand the
final ground inside our city so the
unsullied manning its walls that start -
this episode is not coming as a huge
surprise little do they know it's a trap
anyways back to the outline it states
that Daenerys is too weak she can't walk
or even sit she also has a fever mr.
Wilkins says to Tyrion that in the best
case the nurse will only lose her child
in a miscarriage but he's afraid that
both the nearest and the child will
likely die Tyrion orders maester wolkan
and Sam to make sure both of them
survive the nurses later scurried out of
King's Landing the nurse mr. Vulcan
semi-sentient small force of a few
hundreds a leader heading to Dragonstone
the remaining as solid as well as the
tracking of the gun company along with
grey warmer stink is landing on the
nurses orders her strickland wants to go
be the nearest but Aaron tells him that
the nurse is going to be safe at
Dragonstone
unlike Aegon Targaryen who is inserts
his dungeons Jorgen is following
Daenerys the red woman falls the nurse
from distance Circe explains to Qyburn
how her hatred towards Robert made her
get rid of her firstborn child injury
but her unconditional love that she has
for children structured from killing him
she replaced her baby with a lowborn
shot and killed it instead you know that
your first son is here now your grace
your first boy is in King's Landing are
you willing to kill him now your grace
asks Qyburn he picked his side if he is
fighting for Targaryen for the same
family his father waged war against and
beat his a trader he which
his family respond sir see okay let me
stop right here for a moment to adjust
your comments regarding injury big
illegitimate son of Sir sin Robert
Baratheon some of you claim that the
injury cannot be searched his child
because the prophecy that was told to
her when she was young
however while I'm not stating that the
South line must be hundred percent
accurate I have to say that it's a fact
that Cersei gave a birth for children's
show early on in Game of Thrones if you
paid close attention you'd notice two
scenes to me sir she talks about her
black haired son that supposedly died
shortly after the birth I lost my first
boy he was a fighter too tried to beat
the fever that took him Cersei talks
with Catelyn Stark about it and even
though some could argue that Cersei
could've lied to Catelyn the second
scene completely declines this
possibility in the second scene sir she
talks about her firstborn son with the
father himself Robert Baratheon already
made a full video regarding a theory
which ginjuries this black haired son so
men you finished watching this video it
might want to see all the clues and
hints proving this theory right back to
the outline it continues with Cersei
pauses and nervously asks is it done yet
do we have her not yet your grace but
Qyburn ancestors interrupts a man asks
what is taking so long
your grace you already have their king
in your dungeon sky burning streets and
continues wait they came here but they
don't trust you they came here because
they thought is their best and only
chance to win the great war patience
your grace she's surrounded by many
guards but our men will seize her sooner
or later
they know displays the best very well
sirs response may I ask your grace why
do you want her captured Cabernets
surtseyan continues with once we
initiate wildfire take all of them will
die including her I want her and Jon
Snow to suffer as one watches the other
die and yet can't say one another I want
them to feel the pain I felt when I lost
my children sir she answers the sins
which is to Dragonstone the nurse is
lying in a bed the nearest else juror
she's afraid that she and her child are
going to die the nurse says that this is
how her mother died to jorah thousand
years that she's not going to die and
her child Wanda eater the nurse then
thinks of John and starts crying she
says that they don't even know if John
is still alive she says sir she could
have killed him by now or the night King
could have killed them all dinner says
that regal is likely dead while John
can't help the meter since he doesn't
want to leave
the nearest blames herself for
everything that's happening the juror
tells Danny that everything is going to
be fine Joe tells her how soon enough
all disability hind she and John will
get married their child will be the
prince or princess of gemstone denier
smiles for a moment but then she faints
jerkles for Sam or he looks for Sansa
but can't find her
she has senses guards her senses they
don't know one of themselves she's
probably brilliant somewhere around
Riaan sees aria from a distance and sees
that something is wrong she approaches
sorry and Esther what's the matter or it
says that she can't find sense and he
hasn't seen her since morning she asked
Brienne if she knows where sensei is but
Bryan hasn't seen her either
something is wrong the scene switches to
the red keep the Great Hall did anyone
see you sir she asks her twins garden
one of them responds with know your
grace
good sir says busy Jon Snow whose arms
and legs are chained he's held by the
mountain Qyburn stands beside Cersei
justno plead Cersei he says no please
kill me let her go
within season Savi bruises on her face
and hands since the tries to seem as if
she's brave but you can see fear in your
eyes Cersei smiles
take a drink little though Cersei tell
Sansa what's in it
sense I asked Cersei drink it sirs
response since I looks at John breathing
heavily the scene intensifies Jon shakes
his head and says don't what if I refuse
senses Cersei refused and I'll have your
brother strangle to death
Cersei answers and smiles horrible
ordered the mountain to cut him in two
starts continues the mountain joel is
sword at Erin's down senses cheek or
perhaps I'll have him roasted alive
whatever I found most amusing at the
moment I suppose Janet sends a look at
each other one of them is not going to
make it alive out of his room John says
don't do it Sansa Cersei glances at
sensor she's happy to see her suffer
Jon again says don't another tear runs
down senses cheek
since it looks at John says take care of
our family and drinks a poisoned wine
since that begins choking she gets for
air and collapses to the floor the last
sounds we hear before the screen fades
to black her John sobs echoing to the
castle this is the ending I never
imagined for the Lady of Winterfell
she's been through a lot tormented by
the Lannisters and now killed by the
Lannister has it been foreshadowed
yes multiple times for the previous
season but still it comes as a huge
shock senses death at the hands of
Cersei might have been foreshadowed by
this scene in which census says that she
would never come to King's Landing well
sources there since her she would likely
end up capturing her
it will not set foot in King's Landing
while Cersei Lannister is queen they
want another start prisoner they can
caramel tape
additionally census guards failing to
protect her has also been foreshadowed
in a previous season by Arya in this
scenario basically tell sensor that her
guards can't protect her and therefore
she should find better guards in Iveta
gods Cersei did one sense at that for
quite some time as she thought sensible
responsible for Joffrey's death however
search to later learned that it was in
fact Elena who poisoned Joffrey but I
suppose sir is still somehow blame cents
a for Joffrey's death or perhaps she saw
her as a threat and Cersei was just a
little girl prophecy was told to her
most of the prophecy already came true
but one of the main event that is yet to
come show is Cersei being overthrown by
a younger more beautiful woman it's been
revealed that Cersei has become fully
man throughout the past previous
episodes it senses presence at a capital
sursum I think that she's the one that
will cast her down so she decides to
kill her I do have to say that
unfortunately sensei is not the only
main and some fans favorite characters
that will die in this episode there is
more to come the outline and states that
brains having a series of visions King's
Landing faces a vinter storm we're still
staring at Cersei killed Sansa we're so
servile to Tyrion that his sister has
betrayed them again
their nests were received his turn in
his claims versus sure Tyrion that the
sources his most trusted employee in one
of Circe's most trusted servants Tyrion
tells fares to stay quiet about us for
now Tyrion states that if they tell
anyone else about as the war among the
living will break out in that case the
word gained the dead is lost
where´s agrees their Intel's fares to
try and find out sources plans since
she's clearly not going to provide any
support in this war where soldiers his
little bird said hide young girl to
bring him more information some things
in this part of the outline have been
confirmed by the season it leaks some
parts on the other hand seem to be
supporting some popular theories where
solar skis Alberto said I'd young girl
to bring him more information it says
where is having a few loyal birds in the
capital is not coming as a huge surprise
what is surprising is that months after
the Sultan was sent to me in gammatron
star casting for said girl ages nine to
eleven for one excellent scene with a
leading cast member which would in this
case be Varys additionally it states the
discharge must have a natural southern
accent
educating the dis chat is going to
appear in King's Landing once again
season 8 Lakes match perfectly with the
South line
anyways back to the outline it says that
some time later Tyrion Davos very
slurred glower Lord Mayor lee seonyu i
rehearse strickland grave arm games
really scarce dark-brown Lyanna Mormont
Robin Naren Edmure Tully Arya Brent
centre Clegane and Jamie arrived at
Jagan paid to have a meeting with Cersei
to discuss the city defenses and the war
plans they're having a meeting in a huge
tent one member of sources Queen's Guard
Cerberus Blount arrives so long with
Qyburn he's representing Circe's
interests on this meeting Lord Mayor Lee
as how could I know if Cersei hasn't
killed our King yet Qyburn assures them
in Jon Snow's el being they discuss the
city defenses turn a sky burn if he's
added the junglers points to the
scorpion bolts as they've instructed him
to do it's the only way to kill the
night king of Dragon Tyrion says before
he could answer Tyrion continues by
saying one more thing we need to know
how Cersei plans to use wildfire against
the army of the Dead
Qyburn assure Stephen that he has done
everything is instructed the scorpions
are ready for the night king dragon he
says that Cersei and so destroyed the
night king by catapulting wildfire
against his army of dead sir Bors
notices the absence of the nearest send
s about her whereabouts
Taryn tells him that they need somewhere
in the sky with her dragons after the
meetings over sources representative and
a member of the Queen's Guard leave the
red states Jaime stays the day cannot
just Cersei nor Qyburn that was agrees
and states that they cannot trust them
but I also don't have any choice but to
prepare for the night king and his army
together especially Jon Snow being in
her dungeons or it tells them about a
secret passage into the dungeons of the
red keep various confirms that there is
one indeed or it says that she's going
to save John here Strickland says that
John must be heavily guarded and
therefore she should have a few
experienced companions by her side here
in game she offered themselves to go
with her Oren's is that she must go
alone or otherwise they'd risk being
caught
she says that Cersei must know the
secret passage by now so there might be
a few guards protecting it in dress
Sariah how she plans to pass by the
guards or it says that she has a race
Arya is talking about a passage out of
the castle that she found out following
various and Illyrio mopatis back in the
very first season okay guys this would
be the first half of episode 5 the other
half is screaming in the process and
will be published as soon as possible
this